choix du travail 71 printemps et autant
d'années de passion pour les plantes des
espèces découvertes lors de ses nombreux
voyages partout sur le globe
un hectare d'invitation au japon au
népal en amérique du sud ou en europe
le jardin de mireille comme un havre de
paix un arboretum d'une richesse
éclatante
est-ce que vous avez une idée du nombre
de plantes que vous cultivez oui alors
j'ai plus de plus de 500 arbres et
arbustes plus de 1000 vivace j'ai planté
six ans rozier mais il en reste à peu
près 400 parce que la terre sablonneuse
ne convient pas aux roses il faut une
terre plus argileuse infatigable
botaniste qui vacanciers et habitants du
cru rendent visite chaque été
car la palette se colore au fil des
semaines entre fontaine et aller
foisonnante
le spectacle est juste bluffant mireille
nous embarque dans son sac à dos et nous
fait courir la planète et ce sont tous
ces voyages qui vous inspire le jardin
en partie oui oui mais à chaque fois
certains certains voyages jeu papa je ne
peux pas faire de coin à thème parce que
le japon il ya tellement de plantes qui
viennent du japon que c'est très facile
à faire
le népal le tibet ça va aussi mais là la
grosse partie c'est le japon puisque
toutes les plantes beaucoup de plantes
de terre de bruyère viennent du japon
les camélias les étrangers
et vous en ramener dans vos valises
annaba le droit il fallait bien de
l'imagination pour cultiver cette
abondance au fin fond de la touraine qui
dirait qu'à chanet sur la temps on
trouve un exotisme aussi florissant que
rares peut-être tirer le chapeau est
placé entre deux rayons de soleil
mireille tyrone des herbes son jardin
extraordinaire pour simplement le
partager une passion charmante à
découvrir jusqu'au 30 septembre